argentina dice sí a la vida
con esta y otras consignas cientos de
argentinos protestaron frente a la sede
del congreso en buenos aires contra el
proyecto de ley impulsado por el
gobierno de alberto fernández que busca
un aborto legal seguro y gratuito lo
cual hoy estamos aquí presentes de
manera temática porque es sábado y no
están los diputados en el congreso pero
de manera telemática para que nuestros
diputados entiendan cuál es la voluntad
del pueblo y al mismo tiempo también
ejerzan su rol de representantes y su
rol es representar a la gente no pueden
hacer caso a sus convicciones sino a la
voluntad del pueblo con banderas del
país pancartas cruces y pañuelos azules
que se han convertido en el símbolo de
quienes rechazan la interrupción del
embarazo los ciudadanos cantaron y
corearon arengas de forma pacífica en mi
experiencia personal
y obviamente que en un principio pensé
también pensé en dar una adopción voy mi
hijo tiene 30 años
es el mayor orgullo
actualmente en el país el aborto solo
está permitido cuando hay violación o
riesgo para la vida de la madre
el proyecto de ley contempla que
cualquier mujer podría acceder a esta
práctica hasta la semana 14 y más allá
de ese plazo si se presentan las dos
causales actualmente vigentes la
normativa que en 2018 fue rechazada por
el senado empezará a ser discutida
nuevamente en la cámara a partir de
diciembre